let's try Colin from Oregon Colin
welcome to the show what's on your mind
today
uh David can you hear me okay yes thank
you please
hey uh I appreciate the previous caller
I'd like to ask you some questions about
fentanyl okay now is it fentanyl or is
it fentanyl the way Donald Trump says
honest I honestly don't know I think
it's fentanyl you pronounced it
beautifully
oh I appreciate that
um so I read a lot of stuff just like
everybody else does and the reports that
are more more recent are saying well
China is producing Fentanyl and they're
shipping it to South America and these
immigrants are pouring through our
borders right uh bringing fentanyl but
the truth the honest truth is we have
seen fentanyl in all 50 states yes
so it's getting here somehow the thing
is I miss I was misled
um I thought actually maybe there were
some people in our country that were
producing Fentanyl and just Distributing
it what can we do to stop the flow of
fentanyl you know this is a a very
complex issue that clearly is not going
to be solved with a wall on the U.S
Mexico border now it is true that the
primary source countries for Fentanyl
and related substances that are traffic
to the U.S are Mexico and China
um India is increasingly a source for
both the finished fentanyl but also some
of the precursor chemicals there are
seizures at the border but we need to be
looking at ports of Entry including
airports and and you also have to be
considering that if you fix the issue as
it might be seen fixing it right using
the language of the drug war if you fix
the issue of the fentanyl that's
trafficked in you then incentivize the
domestic production so then you have to
figure that out so I I don't think
there's a simple solution but what I can
tell you is like the issue isn't
something Biden did at the U.S Mexico
border
right they're saying that well if we
just close the border right we could
stop the the
um the what's the word the metaphor of
immigrants pouring in do we really think
that immigrants they do is it I mean the
the numbers the numbers did increase
when Biden took over the numbers that
immigrants did increase but of course we
also said we won't separate your kids
from your parents anymore you know yeah
but I think you have to consider with
that Colin is what the oftentimes these
right-wingers cite the increased number
of apprehensions as evidence that more
people are coming in but remember that
those people are being apprehended
there's a different case to be made
which is oh maybe Joe Biden is having a
better job done at the border where we
are apprehending more people and fewer
are getting in now I'm not saying it is
that way but when the right likes to use
just that metric it's kind of it's it's
quite dumb actually to just use that
metric
and I've talked to many right-wingers
and I said you know that they used a
border wall campaign fund to a grift
like a millions of people and raise a
few million dollars and they're like
what and I'm like yeah you didn't hear
about that Oh you mean the Bannon build
the wall thing
yeah well I think that that Trump didn't
get to build the wall and the thing is
he could have and what they said was
that's what they say is like Biden said
no and stopped all procedures and
there's just fence line just standing by
what so I don't is that true
um I honestly am not sure it's hard for
me to keep track of all of the different
claims that that they make but all of
the ones I've looked into so far have
not been accurate but that one I'm just
not familiar with yeah I live in a
pretty conservative I'm trying to make I
try to make middle ground with a lot of
these folks around here and they tell me
this and I think it's hard to it's just
what you when you get Gish scallops when
they're like look at all these and
you're okay I can only take this one at
a time right but the most of the
responses that I get are largely just
like a like a shock like you said shot
out of a cannon it's so many different
discussions all at once like Mike
Lindell it's too much and this is you
know Sam Harris love them or hate him he
has a really good podcast on this where
he explains why he won't like debate
Brett Weinstein on vaccines because he
said the problem is you know these folks
can very easily come in and set like 10
small fires and you might only have the
tools to put out nine of them and they
go yeah but didn't you see that study
from like Bangladesh were they like
Ivermectin cured everything and then
you're like well no I didn't see it but
now you can't respond then it becomes a
mess I think lose lose
yeah it's not a discussion that's taking
place you're not having a good faith
discussion it's a I have the the whole
alpha male I have to win this discussion
I have to win this argument instead of
maybe understanding you might be
actually wrong about something right
absolutely Colin you could possibly said
it any better
anyway sorry I want to say I'm I'm
grateful for your show and I'm grateful
for you uh thank you so much and have a
nice day you too and have a good holiday
and are you are you doing turkey are you
doing multiple roast chickens what are
you doing our family is very diverse
we're just kind of we're doing a
plethora of options I know we're doing
like a smoked mac and cheese wow I don't
know yeah I don't know if you're into
that are you smoking it with cherry wood
or what are you smoking with
oh we have a Traeger um we just you know
it's just a recipe we've never tried it
before but you gotta use you you baked
the thing and then you you smoke it on a
trigger absolutely you're not gonna use
like Liquid Smoke though you'll use real
smoke
oh absolutely okay good I could tell
from just talking to you you would never
resort to that
sir sir I have high standards when it
comes to culinary science uh thank you
Colin have a great holiday great to hear
from you let's go next uh it's great to
check in and see see what everybody's
plans are I love cooking at home I cook
all the time having a good set of knives
that you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beautiful heavy duty
Ash wood box makes it a really great
gift easy to store as well on the
kamikoto website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below